with the fourth pick in the 2008 NBA
Draft
Russell Westbrook from UCLA get him to
read there he's like thank you thank you
thank you I'm a point guard you know
i'ma try my best and go out and you know
do what I can for the team and try to
help anywhere I can the rent the envy
the year this past season
for the Westbrook feel that way
feel it real I'm a real person
straight for Idol
we'll pull out a piece of one I'm not
going to consider being fake
the
Lahoma City Thunder select James Harden
about
just go there
those guys out you know like Kevin
Durant and Russell there is gonna be a
great honor just some things out there
that you really can't do nothing with
you know they got too much in their bag
but tonight there is one guy this to
look at its what Russell was doing for
Oklahoma City you just think about how
much players around the league
have talked about what it is that bus is
represented on the nightly basis with me
it's just been incredible to have that
kind of drive that kind of desire and
that kind of ability I guess to muster
that kind of energy nightly
[Music]
the rapid
leadership is one thing that taken
Friday
to make other guys better
Conference Finals
I need a little bit more dose of nasty
Oklahoma City Thunder they become the
six team in NBA history go down 200 in a
playoff series and then win three
straight games has done major damage to
the Spurs here
[Music]
[Music]
they are shooting 61% from the fear of
the storms
[Music]
Oh check
[Music]
and throws it down Russell West one
[Applause]
Brideshead layup accident major design
fuck-ups
close it down
sidestep
[Music]
today the game
[Music]
buh-bye
once again
[Music]
an elusive title Lisa
[Applause]
[Music]
they had a remarkable run
[Music]
the deadline for an extension for Hart
is Wednesday night at midnight though
the Thunder basically knew they were
going to try to get a deal done this
month but they didn't want to give
Hardin the Mack James Hardin going from
a title contender and OKC to a
rebuilding project in Houston I think
maybe down the future he may look back
at this and say we have something
special in Oklahoma City if I had it to
do all over again maybe I would stay in
Oklahoma City the main focus is to win
championship every year
you asked me what to do he looking
amazing man and I just don't think he'd
get enough credit he can dribble and you
got the calendars and got all the things
that he needs a hybrid like he has a
fold and so it's tough to stop a guy
like that also disappointed I just play
me that's it TV conversation somehow was
a ball hog and now
the league in assists I know what I'm
able to do I know what I make me do at a
high level every night and nobody those
can do what I can do
basis naturally believe that if they
could I'm pretty sure they would
rustling learn from those mistakes in
the past and you know what I'm not
shooting the ball well but I could still
go rebound
I can still defend I take too much pride
time effort to be able to go out and
compete and play hard every night can't
take it away from me
[Music]
can we look at every evaluating to some
time to kind of go back to the drawing
board and see how it can be better one
thing we know about this guy right here
he's going to work hard he's will do
everything possible to make sure that
he's ready to go to get back on the
floor
[Music]
but he was talking about he was first
team All Defense I didn't know what the
hell he was talking about 30 42 at a
time by Libya dreamers
Westbrook's suffering a face fracture he
underwent surgery today
was Bork's 10-plus assist in
50 years and Russell as has made history
it's been a it's been a treat to watch
him all your life well I don't really
need nothing to drive me to be
to be where I want to be
and our MVP is from the Oklahoma City
Thunder Russell Westbrook my job as a
bartender compete at a high level
I've been blessed to be played this game
every night I try leave it on the floor
and that's the nature the game when I
taste lingers I leave it on the floor
I'm always happy with the result
coming on strong
Thunder
[Music]
[ __ ] turn around
[Music]
what off
are you gonna follow Kevin's who'd be
the supportable when we support a
consensus decision we're gonna go Timmy
after what we did this year in failure
kevin durant decision to leave the
Thunder for the 2-time defending Western
caucus chance in Golden State
started to
warriors versus thunder if you want to
hold up that trophy that was sitting
over there the Thunder have to be to
Warriors and the lawyers on freedom
if Russell Westbrook averages the
triple-double and leads the league in
scoring look at what we're witnessing
I think we just try to get better Matt I
think if you all in the championship you
gotta be the best things to do it and I
think as a team you got a sec
this might be the greatest season I've
ever seen a player have to average a
triple-double is some haven't been done
in 50 years there's a reason why but to
be able to do that the amount of energy
to go out and do that every single night
is amazing and he's not getting a little
wussy triple-doubles you see guys get
triple doubles why don't we have a
thirteen one the average 28 Watson came
I mean I think it aligns with our
talents to be redundant basilar thing
you should do it in that Southfield
[Music]
yesterday and the winner of the 2017 Kia
NBA Most Valuable Player Award is
Russell Westbrook
[Music]
my parents man
you guys did any and everything to make
sure be it my brother had anything he
wanted I told myself I go cry
this is his third season in the world
and his brothers out there averaging a
triple-double and we always talk about
well he's not there so he's not dead let
me tell you what he is he's a winner but
he's a guy that recognizes some of the
things that he can be better at I know
that when you do so much of the game
got so much impact on the game
the loss of Nipsey Hussle and so when
you see Russ honour in this man is
because he led by it's out
[Music]
they know what that means
Oh
I expect a lot out of myself
for myself to become
the 11 years the longest
ten active player with the same team
what Oh what are you talking about night
it was time to start the rebuild and
also left with just really didn't
type of timeline to this type for this
Thunder team
the Futter training their franchise
player the guy that
and both the Thunder and Russell
Westbrook in the representation in that
I'm sorry lobster diversity today
James Harden desire to reunite with
Russell Westbrook's early and mutual
desire they decided they wanted to play
together again
you